seriously though how do I look how's my
posture this is these seems unnatural
but this seems lazy I don't think it
looks lazy okay I think you look very
relatable right now relatable yeah that
I'm like he works an average amount and
I can relate to that that's exactly me
yeah
if cornnuts were political what would
their views on the world be core nuts
are too enlightened to have a single
viewpoint yeah they're kind of like a
corn kernel exactly hasn't really fully
reached its nut stage no no they're
they've evolved past that ah are they
corn are they nuts I think they're
technically corn they have a nuts I dare
ya crazy corn is what they should have
called right so I feel like they are on
a higher plane
yeah down at us having political
disputes but yet they are aware of the
true reality sour cream ones especially
what's the best thing in the world to
put on your feet do you know my feet are
really hairy I did not know that nor was
I gonna ask about that but I'm glad you
told me they're about as hairy as my arm
what do you do with that I don't always
need to wear socks actually I'm not even
kidding so I definitely I did this this
show once that never reached the light
of day and I was a challenge of putting
your feet in ice water okay and I beat
everybody I said how long you could keep
your feet in ice water without the pain
causing you to pull him out and I didn't
feel the cold and so this was actually
it was it was it was administered by an
astronaut okay okay a real NASA
astronaut super board astronaut no he
was he was doing he's teaching us what
it took to be an astronaut okay six
minutes was what it took to show that
you had pain tolerance after six minutes
I'm the only one left and I'm like well
uh my feet are hairy he's a huge built
in socks this is unfair even when I was
a child yeah I knew this when my dad had
one of his friends over an adult friend
and we were like on a plane in the
sprinkler and my dad's friend said your
son's feet are really hairy like they're
five years old
what a terrible
yeah explain the essence of a grace
helbig the essence of a grace helbig
mm-hmm the essence doesn't smell great
today I will let you know that but I'll
let you mean essence like smell not not
the you know it's debatable ephemeral a
defining characteristic yeah I don't
think I've smelled you ever don't let's
keep it that way because I do not I need
a shower a shower before I came and I
put on two different types of deodorant
and Cologne
it was a cocktail of essences so I would
imagine but you don't smell overpowering
like when a guy walks by and you can
smell the clothes oh it's yeah okay you
know I put deodorant on my neck and
pretended that I got a shower yeah it's
called the college shower yeah yeah yeah
I don't raise him for breeze on your
butt yeah like an old Febreze but okay
Michael welcome to your challenge
awesome okay so did I win
no well we'll find out oh we haven't
done it yet not yet okay here is the
game that I've created for you you've
heard of the gallon challenge on YouTube
yeah and or the milk challenge today I
decided that we were gonna do the
balanced
Elune because I thought that that's how
British people say balloon but turns
Allen Fallon but turns out they just
said sweetly call a gallon of balloons
yeah yeah very good yeah sure everyone
knows that that's that's in facts with
grace okay okay so this is how the game
works in one of these balloons there is
a toy a prize so our goal is to find
that prize whoever finds it first wins
yeah however we will be blindfolded oh
so okay and our weapon of choice for
destroying these balloons cuz we learned
that they're very hard to pop if you try
and just step yeah they they fly way is
a pen so careful pencil a mechanical
pencil could spare no expense here okay
okay and the other person that gets
said just say I won that's what we say
okay and the price okay I won I won okay
ready yeah oh okay okay I'm good
are you blindfolded yeah on your mark
get set go
it's the balloon wait how do I know
through something I don't know I assume
that we'll hear it somehow no then this
one's coming from behind me oh Jesus
yeah
don't sit I'm gonna pop them cuz you
feel it in your bottom hole okay I
didn't know that's a popping really well
though they are this is a great device
have we already popped it to wait I just
heard something
wait did you think that one was my shoe
oh no and it's completely turned around
where are the balloon how am I gonna
know that I found that is that part of
the trick getting input a toy in them
this is just just needlessly killing
yeah James asked James gonna tow me in
one and James if there's no joy no way
that's you I know wait what well you
touched it first that I feel like a
steel it's just cartage balloon carnage
ever hey wait I'm pushing them all away
from oh wait oh shoot I thought I won I
won what is this yeah damn it like a
spark plug or you can take your
blindfold off okay what is it oh it's
all just a little it's a little British
post office British posso receptacle
well that's appropriate cuz I'll be
mailing you all of my hate mail for
winning this congratulations Michael
thank you are the victor how do you feel
I feel like this was well deserved yeah
I feel I feel less than
why don't we had a breath is such a sad
the biggest question problem we
literally just crawl on the floor for
about 30 seconds it both of us are like
oh what a merits enough for that for a
lifetime
oh no more sports this is the stupidest
sport that's what we found the answer to
this was not stupid thank you
I was fishing for a company yeah yeah
well make sure that you guys have you
want to listen to the full interview
with Michael go over to iTunes and
search not too deep with grace Helbig
and go subscribe to Michael here on
YouTube awesome thanks grace of course
what's weird what's the youtubes I'm
gonna get into words and letters for the
thing that they can go find me yeah
youtube.com slash the best just kidding
it's a sauce but I am the best as
clearly was shown today yeah so I'm
gonna go give up just cry you're gonna
shower thanks Michael have fun with you
if you personified fruit which fruits
would be the mean girls blueberries oh
yeah right not suspect that
[Music]